hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
functionalizing genome editing
techniques on a broad
range of cellular targets this webinar
is part of the cell biology virtual
event
and i'm susie valdez and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots so let's get
started
before we begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as
many questions as you'd like during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on that continuing education credits tab
located at the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits
i now present today's speaker dr chandra
miller
an assistant member and center of
advanced genome engineering
at st jude children's research hospital
in the department of cell and molecular
biology
for a complete biography of our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr miller welcome you may now begin your
presentation
yeah thanks so much i want to thank the
organizers for inviting me
to talk today i'm really excited about
this virtual event and i just love that
science is still moving forward even in
the middle of what we're going through
as a world as a country together um so
as she said i'm gonna be talking to you
about functionalizing genome editing
events um
and i'm going to tell you a little bit
about what we do at the cage
this is called center for advanced
genome engineering we call ourselves the
cage
so at the cage we basically oops i
missed the slide there you go
we have three main missions first we
provide genome editing technologies for
investigator-initiated projects we
basically help other people at st
jude do genome editing we also help
or we also do independent r d uh so that
we can stay at the forefront of this
emerging and fast paced
field and then we also support key
initiatives such as our gene and cell
therapy programs here at st jude
particularly in car t and then the
hemoglobinopathy
areas we spend about 75 percent of our
time helping others do genomic and we do
a broad range of editing in terms of
breadth and scope i would just give you
some idea of what we're kind of doing on
a day-to-day basis
uh we provide six major services uh
to investigators um i'm gonna tell you
about those now and i'll give you kind
of an idea of the numbers of things that
we're doing
i think i'm doing this probably to try
to get street cred um but
we'll go we'll go with it um so first
are the services that we provide we
design and validate guide our days
um we also create custom cell lines so
people can come to us and say i want to
make this point mutation and the cell
line and we'll do
it pretty much any cell type and any
modification
[Music]
we also create pre-clinical animal
models typically mouse and wrap
we also do targeted next generation
sequencing for crispr edited samples
and we facilitate high throughput
genetic screens these are typically
pooled guide rna
libraries uh knockout knock knockout
activation and inhibition and then we
recently started editing or offering
edited cell pools
and this is because not every project
demands a
single cell derived clones which is what
we do in the custom created uh
cell line creation um and we can also
get
editing rates that are so high that we
can actually give them edited cell pools
instead of single cell derived clones
so we do a large range of things and we
also do a large breadth
of targets and so just to give you some
ideas of numbers um in terms of
guidelines that we've designed and
validated both in r
p and plasmid format we've really
stopped counting because there's just so
many because of all our projects really
start with it with
with that um the next thing we
this crispr sorry the creating custom
cell lines um we've created 495 single
cell derived custom clonal
populations uh in less than three it's
been a little over three years i guess
less than four years
um we have also created 87 animal models
um in any given week we do 4 000 samples
per week
for targeted next generation sequencing
and we've created 48 custom pooled
libraries and just this year we've
created 44 edited cell
pools so all this to say is that we're
doing a lot of genome editing and
in different species and then we're also
doing it in a wide range of genetic loci
so when we think about genome editing
tools we want something that's going to
be super robust and work across a lot of
different platforms
so we rely mostly on traditional genome
editing
and what i mean by traditional genome
editing is that we rely on creating a
targeted double-stranded break
with crispr cast 9 mostly sp cas9
and so you can see that here we're
creating a target edible stranded break
and then
that double stranded break gets repaired
by one of two major repair pathways in
the million cells
and that's typically non-homologous and
joining or homology directed repair
and you probably have seen a slide like
this or you will see one of these today
and i'm not going to go into the details
of it but other than to say that you can
use
a double-stranded brake and the repair
by the cell's endogenous repair pathways
to create a lot of different editing
events these are targeted mutagenic
events
so you can create point mutations
knockouts translocations deletions
inversions all kinds of different things
the two things i really want to bring
your attention to are one that the
repair pathway called non-homogenous and
joining is the preferred pathway in the
million
cells so i've shown this here by this
big fat arrow
this is basically just showing you that
that happens more often than the
homology directed repair or the hdr
events
um and then the last thing is that we
use we basically
all of our projects or most of our
projects start with a double-stranded
break and so we want to make sure that
we have guide rnas that are going to
give us
efficient double-stranded break creation
um so we
we wanted to basically figure out what
assay we wanted to use to figure out
when our guide rnas were actually active
and i just i'm sure you guys know this
but the guide rna is the thing that
directs the cas9 nucleus to the specific
site and
the genomic loci so we want to make sure
that that thing that we're changing out
that guide rna is active before we start
our project
so the assays that are available for
detecting grna activity are
uh there's several of them and they all
they mostly start with the same um
upstream pathway uh so uh you basically
start out with your guide rna plus your
cast nine it can be delivered in
multiple different formats then you're
going to transfect that into a pool of
cells these can be
some of those cells will be transfected
some of those cells will not be
transfected some will have breaks some
won't have breaks
then you're going to harvest genomic dna
and then do a pcr around the
the modification site shown here as a
red x
and then you're going to want to do one
of these downstream applications or
these downstream assays and i'm just
showing you some of the most commonly
used assays
one is called t7e1 or a cell one assay
one is targeted next generation
then you have tide or ice and then you
also have an assay called ida
and so a few years back we wanted to
figure out which of these aspects was
going to work with the best for us
and look at the pros and the cons of
each and so in work led by monica
simonette
uh with the help of sam peters colin
florian florian
florin gloria i'm sorry uh and patrick
collin
connelly um we basically did a survey
and so we published this two years ago
um it's in scientific reports i'm not
going to go into the details of it but i
do want to tell you the take home
message from this paper
um basically what worked for us we had
several different boxes that we needed
to check
and ngs was the one that did those
things checked all those boxes
so the things that we wanted to check uh
were i didn't we need to be able to
identify active guidance we needed to be
able to show indel sizes how big the
indels were
we needed to be able to show sequence
identities what the actual indels were
and then we wanted to be able to
accurately portray editing events both
in pools of cells and then also in
clones
and then lastly we needed to make sure
that we had a very high throughput
assay because we're doing a lot of this
we're doing you know hundreds tens of
thousands probably at this point
of different guide validation assays
and so ngs really provided this platform
for us
so as with most assays there are
limitations to
um different these different assays and
because all of these assays are
pcr-based remember i told you that that
the upstream workflow is all similar and
it involves doing a pcr step
um there are some limitations that are
common among all four of these assays
so because of the pcr because it's
pcr-based there is a pcr bias
so smaller amplicons will be
preferentially amplified
so large endells will be preferentially
amplified
um and because it's pcr based and we
have you know primers that are going to
be marking the thing that we're
amplifying and sequencing
we can't detect all gross chromosomal
aberrations so large things like if a
chromosomal arm got lost
or an endo was so large that it deleted
a primer binding site we wouldn't be
able to pick those up then there's also
this limitation of amplicon size so
we're able to
basically efficiently amplify off
genomic dna about a thousand base pairs
and so
i would say all of these assays are
limited to a thousand base pairs or less
and you can see the specifics there
the thing that was unique to uh ngs as
far as the limitation was that there's a
high barrier to entry this kind of you
know the
reagents can be expensive you need
specific equipment and there's expertise
required
and not only setting up the library but
also analyzing the data that comes out
so that can really
you know make scare people off of doing
ngs and so
just to give you an idea of what a
genome editing workflow looks like for
us
and for most people and followed by nds
i wanted to give you a workflow of this
so first we'll basically introduce the
guidernase it can be into cells
or into embryos to make those
preclinical animal models mouse or rat
then you allow the guide rnas to do
their thing and you culture the cells
um you can culture them either either a
single cell clones
or you can plate them as pools of cells
or you can even put if you do the embryo
injections you can put them back into a
mom and let the mom do the culturing
while she's pregnant
next you're going to harvest genomic dna
you're going to do a pcr around the
region of interest and then you're going
to add indexes so that you can pull all
the samples together
sequence with ngs and then analyze your
ngs data
and we do this with something called
crispy which i'll tell you about in a
few slides
so going into more detail about how we
do our library ngs library setup
we have dual indexes and we use a 2
2-step pcr
setup so what this looks like is you
would have your region of interest this
is where your guide rna is cutting in
between these
two primer sites you have a forward
primer and a reverse primer that are
specific to the
the locus of interest and then you have
these orange
overhangs that we call these partial
alumina adapters on the five prime
end you would amplify in the first step
you would amplify the gene specific
region
and then you would put that would put on
the partial aluminum adapters and then a
second step
you would put on you would use those
partial aluminum adapters
to do an spcr and put on your indexes
and in our lab we have 44 forward
primers and then we have 384 reverse
primers
that are common that we use across all
of its all different projects
and the the forward primer has an index
of six base pair and
and the reverse primer has a 10 base
pair index so what this means is that we
can
we can do a whole bunch of pcrs we can
we can take it from wells of plates
we can figure out what index goes to
which well and then we can demultiplex
when they
pull all those samples together and so
you get results
an amplicon that looks like this you do
traditional
ngs we use illumina's mysq platform for
most of our applications
and we are able to deconvolute those
indexes and figure out where the editing
event is occurring in which well
so we get this result that looks like
this you get a whole bunch of fastq
files and this is pretty scary for most
people it was scary for us the first
time we thought and we're like what are
we going to do with all this data
there's lots of data it takes up a lot
of space but how do we actually get
stuff that we want out of it
um basically inside those fast few files
you can see the efficiency of the
editing you can see the size of the
inbuilt and you can actually see the
sequencing identity of what's going on
with your genome edit
and so i like to make this joke because
my mom was a huge x-files fan
um the truth is out there i should
really probably say the truth is in
there
um inside those few files you can really
find the information that you want
want to see with the limitations that i
expressed earlier
so um in a herculean effort i guess
patrick connolly in the lab he basically
is a biologist trained biologist
had no formal experience in coding he
basically learned python using
codecademy online the free online coding
course
just so that we could analyze our ngs
data efficiently and he came up with
this pipeline called crispy
cute name we like the name because
python programs which is this is written
in python
end with dot py and then we also could
make this
cool little logo on the bottom left that
has a python in it with the s
so we like the name i guess you can tell
so we have this paper published this
last year
so if you want more details you can go
there but i'm also going to walk you
through this paper in a little bit more
detail so you can understand
some of the things i'm going to tell you
based on the analysis that we have
so to be completely upfront there are
quite a few ngs analysis programs out
there
and to be completely honest a lot of
them are written most of them are
written more eloquently
than ours because again ours was written
by a biologist for biologists so it's
very simple
and it's highly functional um and so you
can totally use one of these other
analysis pipelines but i'm gonna show
you some of the advantages that crispy
has
and the reason why we still use it in
our lab i guess we developed this about
seven years so we've been using this for
about seven years now
the things that we needed our ngs
pipeline to do were the following so we
needed to make sure that we could run it
locally we didn't want to rely on
somebody's
server to actually be able to run our
ngs analysis if it goes down or they
take it down for maintenance we would
be stuck so we needed to be able to run
it locally
we need to be able to run it on lots of
different samples we're doing thousands
of samples every week so
we couldn't just do one or two at a time
we need to be able to do a lot at one
time
we also need to be able to look at more
than one donor search at a
time so more than one edit happening in
individual clones and across multiple
clones
and then importantly we needed a master
summary file so that we could look
through a lot of editing events and be
able to figure out what we actually want
in that you know in the needle in the
haste that kind of scenario where do we
how do we find the needle quickly
and so to go over how crispy works again
written by a biologist for biologists so
it's super simple
um we basically take the sequence the
fastq files and we treat it like text
and so we start out with a reference
sequence which is basically just the
amplicon that you sequenced around the
modification site
and then we asked the program we give
the program a start sequence or seek
start
which is basically a 10 to 14 base pair
sequence on the five prime end of
the reference sequence or your amplicon
then we also give the program a 10 to 12
10 to 14 base pair sequence that we call
the sequence end
at the three prime end of your amplicon
and then we ask the program to measure
the distance from the start seek to the
end seek
just by just literally as characters how
long is the seek start the seek end
so let's say in this example our
sequence from seek start to the end was
250 base pairs
then we would tell the program to look
for anything that had the start seek
and the seek end and then to measure the
distance compared to the reference
the reference length is 250 base pairs
and our sequence that matched the start
seeking nc
is 249 base pairs it would report it
back as a minus one
if it's 250 base pairs it would report
it back as a zero and so on
and so that will report out the end of
and you can see here just showing the in
mill link so zero again would be the
wild type link and then you can see if
they're missing or adding
base pairs it would be reported back and
because we're not only doing
knockouts where we're looking for
inbelts we're also looking for knock in
modifications or
modifications made by homology directed
repair and so what we can do is we can
use we can give the program a test
sequence so what this means is we say
okay any sequences that have the start
sequence and have the end sequence
how often do they have this exact match
to a test sequence so you can think
about this as saying control f
and your fast q files of how often do i
find the thing that i'm actually looking
for if you think about like a word
processor document
so those are the things that's how it
works we basically look at links how far
how long is the sequence that we're
looking at in the reads compared to the
reference
and then two how often do we find the
thing that we're looking for
so as far as crispy input in this
example i'm going to show you where we
were looking for the activity of these
two different guides we're putting in
guide 10 or guide 14.
in terms of input what you need to do is
basically just put six things in
um and this is how that we this is how
the program is
available on github uh is command line
and that scares people i it scares me i
don't even know really what command line
means except for
this part but i've been a programmer and
i feel comfortable using this
um what this means is you're going to go
through and these six things on the left
uh the the text that's written or
highlighted in red
you're going to change the text in
between those apostrophes
so the things you're going to be
changing are number one is just giving
it a name so if i wanted to call it
locus one i could call locus one i could
call it vhl if i wanted to give it the
gene name
so whatever you wanna call it then
you're gonna put in your reference
sequence which again is just the
amplicon the sequence between those two
primers
and then you're gonna give it your seek
start that small sequence of the five
prime end
your seek n which is that small sequence
of three prime n
and then you're going to leave five
alone because it's going to be in you're
going to look in all of your fast q
files
and then you can give it a list of as
many test sequences as you want um so in
this case we basically gave it two test
sequences so guide 10 so the full 23
base pairs including the pam sequence of
guide 10
and the full 23 base pairs of guide
sequence um for guide 14.
that's it six things really five things
that you have to input and one of those
is just the name
i also want to mention when we were
doing a review when we had reviews for
this paper um one of the reviews is they
didn't like that it was
modifying the command line that's not
like how programmers typically do things
um and so uh jake's still in the lab
he's a new member of the lab he actually
made something called pretty crispy um
which is a has a graphical
user interface or a gui um so that you
can do this more robustly this is
limited that you can't do it as
as much as many samples as what we're
talking about
but it is out there for folks if they
want to use it
and that's also available on github all
right so what is we've talked about the
input we talked about how it works what
does the output look like
so this is a master summary file
remember i told you that was one of the
things that we really wanted to be able
to do is to find that needle and
haystack very efficiently
and so i'm going to walk you through we
have two outputs one is the master
summary file which is just a csv file or
an excel document basically that is
sortable and searchable
and on the left you have here the
fastview file name that's the well in
which the reads actually occur so we use
those index that we did in our two set
pcr
um to basically go back so we know okay
this sample was in plate 1 b07 so if the
hit that we are looking for is in
plate 1v07 we can go directly to that
and expand that clone
the next column is labeled sample and
this is user inputted so this is
actually blank besides the column header
and you can put in whatever sample name
you want just to be descriptive for your
own purposes
then the next column is total which is
the total number of reads that you have
for each of the samples so
the first sample our negative control
had 980 reads
and then we're going to go into our test
sequences so this is that list of
sequences remember in the previous slide
i had g10 and i had the 23 base pairs of
the guide 10
target site so we're looking for how
often does that guide 10 site occur with
zero base pairs of mismatch
where it basically is perfect a perfect
match
and what you can see here is that in our
negative control we have almost
all the reads match back to guide 10
it's not going to be 100 because if
there was a sequencing error in any of
those base pairs
you would basically you would uh it
would not be considered an exact match
um so it's never 100 but that's why we
always include a negative control so we
can see what the sequencing error is for
any of our different test sequences or
our
our links but then you can see with
guide 10 you're losing that guide 10
site
and so that is a good indication that
we're getting the modification that
we're looking for
the next column is called total indels
and this is this is a quick and easy way
of checking to see how much activity you
have
because it's going to report back the
percentage of reads that are not wild
type links so again in our example i
told you that the wild type link was 250
so anything that's not 250 will be
reported back in this column so i can
quickly and easily see that guide 10 is
the most active guide rna and
out of the two guide 10 and guide 14.
and then after the total indel column
you can actually see
the total the top indels and their
frequencies so
on the right you can see it says number
one endel number one uh dash reads
so the number one in dell is a zero so
that means uh in all of the samples
actually zero is the most common in dell
so
no indel is created this length is the
wild type links
and then you can see as you go on you
can see in sample
g10 number one you can see that
sorry indel number two is a plus one and
it occurred at 15.7 percent of the time
and then at the very end of our master
summary our csv file
we have some qc checks which you can
look into the paper i'm happy to discuss
in the q a section but i'm going to kind
of ignore for right now
the second file that we output with
crispy is a text file and if you think
about the master summary file you might
have been like okay there's you know
this is good it's got the summary what's
going on but i don't see any sequences
the sequences are actually outputted in
the text file and in the text file
we're going to give you the top exact
matches and the number of frequencies of
those reads uh the number of times those
reads occur in each of the wells
so in this case i'm showing you the
negative control first that that plate
1b07 negative control just transfected
with gfp
and i've highlighted for the
presentation the guide 10 and the guide
14 with our respective colors and the
arrow indicates where the double
stranded break would occur
and so what you can see here is that i
can immediately look through and i look
if you look on the right hand side
you can see that the length of these
amplicons are all the same
and you can see that uh the top one has
644 reads
uh and that exactly matched that and
then after that you go down to only 11
then 10 then 9 reads and what this is a
sequencing error so
anytime a base pair is not exactly
matching it's going to be bend
separately
and so you can easily go through and
i've highlighted and read those
sequencing errors
so no cutting no editing in the negative
control which is what we would expect
then if we look at our experimental
samples where we put in guide 10 or
guide 14 i can also immediately check by
looking at the links or the size
of the amplicons you can see on the
right-hand side it looks kind of like i
call it the river it kind of looks like
a river
because the amplicon sizes are no longer
the same length and you can look to see
that they have what the sizes are so
minus
a plus one a minus 2 minus 15 and so on
one thing i do want to point out
is that with crispy because we're
looking at either lengths or
exact matches in the link section it's
going to bend things that are the
similar link together
so in this example with guide 14 there's
actually two different minus 45 so you
see minus 45 at the top circled
at 23 if you go down to the
guide 14 text file on the bottom you can
see there's actually two
different wild type or sorry two
different minus 45
indel so two distinct indels have been
together in the master summary but you
can parse those out in the text file
so it is important to look at both the
master summary file and then the text
files to know exactly what's going on in
each of your wealth
crispy also allows you to look at
multiple hdr events and you can analyze
them concurrently and this is important
and we do this actually more than you
would think in this example we wanted to
make a
heterozygous modification in which we
had a what we call a clean head
where one oil does not have an endel in
it and one a little has a modification
so in this example i'm showing this
thing that says mod c to t
um and we basically wanted to make the
modification that's shown in red
but we also wanted to make sure that the
other little was we didn't want
homozygous clones we only wanted to be
heterozygous to recapitulate what
happens in the patient population
and so what we did is we put in a
blocking oligo or what we call block
ssodn and what this is is um we made a
silent modification highlighted in red
the c
where we basically changed a base pair
in the wobble position of the amino acid
so we chose the codon but not the amino
acid that's that's being expressed
and so what this will do is it will trap
that second allele so that we don't get
an endell event on it or once we get an
editing event it doesn't have a
subsequent uh cut and an end-all event
so in this case what we're going to do
is we're going to put a guide rna in
the cast nine in and then we're going to
put in these two different blocking
modifications so four
blocks are two different ssodins one the
block mod and one blocking
oligo and so looking at our crispy
analysis we can quickly um look at our
test sequences where we put in
the you know about 10 base pairs on
either side of the block uh mod
escosodium and then also
of the blocking esodian and we can tell
that the block mod
um showed up at thirteen point four
percent and then the block only showed
up at ten point four percent
so we know that we're getting the
editing that we want we can also look at
the indels the total index will click
52.8
and then on the right hand side you can
see the top end elves
and looking at our text file it's easy
to see in our negative control
one major read some subsequent
sequencing error then you can look in
our edited sample you can see the wild
type read is the top read
and then after that you can see our
block mod and block sequences and then
the indels showing up after that
oftentimes um we we aren't creating
pools we're actually wanting to go
through single cell clones and you can
actually get
more bang for your buck you can get
several different clones or several
different types of
genetically modified cells from one's
round of screening so in this case we
were able to use our master summary file
to quickly and easily find the clones
that we were looking for
and some bonus clones so i've
highlighted just three different
outcomes so there's roman numeral one
two and three
um and in green you can see wild type
plus block mod was that
that's basically the genotype of the
clone and i we knew this because
g6 is basically the wild type sequence
and it's about 50
d6 and about 50 of that blocking
modification
ssodn so those those equal about 50 50
to 100 percent
um the modification two is the block mod
block and again in yellow you can see
that the block mod sodium test sequence
and the block
uh sodium sequence are about 50 50. and
then for number three
um down at the bottom in orange you can
see that we also were able to get
knockout clones
um where we have all the alleles are out
of frame and we also got some other
things we got wild type clones that we
could use the controls
we also got some that were
heterozygously knocked out with one wild
hybrid and one knockout clone
um so you could use these all as
controls and if you know what you have
quickly and efficiently you know which
ones to
uh to amp to expand and freeze down
all right so one thing you know i
mentioned that there's all these other
ngs analysis pipelines
um but one of the things that where i
think crispy really shines is in this
master summary file and
really it's the only uh pipeline out
there that i know of that actually has a
master summary file
i wanted to compare this uh the output
of crispy to crispresso too because it's
one of the most widely used
analysis uh tools it's beautiful it
gives you these beautiful graphs
beautiful pie charts i love it a lot of
different ways but we still use crispy
because of this master summary file um
just because one of the reasons is the
output output um so for crespresso 2
for every sample you for every amplicon
you get
basically 123 files per amplicon per
sample
and so if you had a 384 well plate which
is what we typically would screen for
a a knockout or a knock-in modification
you would get 47 000 files so this is a
lot of files it would be very hard to
sift through to figure out which clone
has the modification that you want
in comparison crispy basically gives you
two files and that's regardless of the
number of amplicons and regardless of
the sample number
and so if you have a 384 well plate
you'd have two files if you had 10
you know 10 000 wells you would have two
files and so it makes it a lot easier
and our master summary file is a csv
file which is basically a
sorry a phone's reading basically a
excel document that is searchable and
sortable
and if you have any more questions about
this it is published and we do have this
crispy um
video tutorial um if you can find the
link in the paper
all right so i've got to walk through
kind of what we're doing at the cage
this broad range of editing and lots of
different you know boats and animals
and also in cell lines and screens we're
doing all this different stuff and we're
using ngs and crispy as our pipeline
so i thought i'd give you some of the
tricks and tips that we've learned over
the last eight years
um or so uh and and hopefully this will
help you with your
your your experiments so one of the
things that we've learned
is that ngs can really help you
determine the allylic frequency
and so what i mean by that a lot of
times people well sometimes people come
to me and i'll say okay
you want to knock out the scene how many
copies are there and they say oh it's
human it's got two copies and i think oh
well is it you know a cancer is a
derived cell line or
or you know that it's only got two
copies um and and people are sometimes
surprised but it shouldn't be
um that their most cell lines that we
use in lab are polyploidy
um and they can actually be very
polyploidy especially for some specific
um
chromosomes so in this case we were able
to use ngs to figure out that in
n2a's there's actually seven copies of
this gene and we did this by looking at
the frequency of each of those endel so
on the bottom i've colored
um the different indels and you can see
that there's a 14
um that occurred at 18 uh minus five
that was at 26
a plus one at 27 and a minus four at 27
28.
um and we were having a hard time
wrapping our minds like how many little
does this is this truly a clone that we
want to keep
and if you take 100 divided by 7 it's 14
and so what we found is that basically
you know we had 1 minus 14 2 minus 5's 2
plus 1's and 2 plus
2 minus 4. and you can see that aligned
here there's 2 minus 4 2 distinct minus
4s and 2 distinct plus ones
so you can use that ratio to figure out
how many copies you have
and without even doing d-banding uh
carry typing in your clones and this is
fairly easy to do especially for triplet
and tetraploid clones it gets a little
harder when it's over four copies
another thing that i think is a little
bit surprising to most people is that
within a population um and culture it's
it's quite heterogeneous in terms of
allylic
number um so you know sometimes you'll
see deep banding or you'll see something
printed the carry type that says okay
the cell line is diploid or the cell
line is triploid
um when you actually go through and you
start looking at hundreds of clones you
see in that population you actually have
template triplets and tetraploid clones
um if it's if it's said that it's
triploid
so here's an example where i've just
highlighted and green the aaa clones and
i i did this because if you look at the
indel
ratio so for example uh 18b09
the second one down the first green one
you can see that there's a minus 11 at
63 percent which is roughly 66 so
basically two alleles had to minus 11
and one a little had a minus one which
is represented around 33
so all the green ones are triploid um
the red one is tetraploid because you
have basically fifty percent minus four
uh plus one at twenty three percent and
a minus two at the twenty three percent
so basically fifty twenty five 25 25
and then you also have diploids that are
at 50 50 and then you have some clones
actually quite a few clones that are
homozygous where you don't really know
how many alleles because all the the
modifications are the same
so you can determine the heterogeneity
within a cell population and this helps
us out but we try to help the end user
by picking clones that represent the
population the best so in this case
we had mostly triploids so we would have
picked template clones and we would have
picked
clones um two clones we tried to give
them two clones we would pick clones
that have
the same zygosity if at all possible
that limits some of the variability
downstream
also sometimes genes are you can't knock
them out
they're essential to the viability or a
cell line is dependent on a specific
gene
and so in this case we were not able to
get a clone that was completely knocked
out but we were able to find dose
response clones
so i'm going to show you i'm have a star
basically we didn't knock out all three
alleles but we were able to
knock out one so you can see this minus
eight and in the one
and you have one wild type which is the
zero and then you also have a minus six
which i'm calling
that's why i have the asterisk because
it's wild type because it's just missing
two amino acids so it probably expresses
like wild type
and it's in-frame mutation we were also
able to find a clone that had 50 50
expression so on the bottom you can see
there's a minus 17 and a zero at 50 50
ratio so that's going to have 50 of the
uh protein expression uh potentially
knocked out
and then you we also oops wrong way we
also have a
a clone that has just one uh allele uh
remaining one wild type allele so you
can actually look at the dose response
of having less and less protein in the
cells
um if there's no compensation uh and
that's something you can easily do with
our crispy program at ngs also we use
ngs to genotype pups to know which pups
to breed which pups have the
modification that you want and which
pups have them at a high rate
that modification at a high ratio so in
this example we're just trying to create
a simple knockout animal i've
highlighted in green
the indels that are in frame and then
i've hided it highlighted in red
the indels that are out of frame and
what you can see is maybe we choose
we would definitely choose not to do a1
because a1 has two end frames and that
won't create our knockout modification
but pup a4 has two different red endells
so we might use that one because we can
breed it and get two different lines out
of it if you want to have two
independently derived
lines to compare
all right another thing that we've
started doing with our nds analysis
is looking for dependencies and this is
really we do this for two different
reasons
um one is because uh we you know we're
trying to knock out sometimes people
give us a gene and we think oh this
might be essential
um in the cell line it looks like it is
we're getting mostly in-frame mutations
and when we screen the clones and so we
can actually go back and do this
dependency or fitness assay
and i'll explain it just a second and
then the second reason why we use this
is to follow up on hits from uh
knockout screens where we say okay you
know if we knock out this gene and we
apply the stress it causes the cells to
either
increase and differentiate
differentiation or decrease and so we
can use that to follow up and validate
hips from screens essentiality screens
so what does this look like this assay
looks as follows so we basically would
have a cell line so in this case
non-six wild-type cells um and red is
gonna be the wild type links
um so we're saying that 97 of the
amplicons when we did that
uh when we did that pcr were wild type
links and then there's uh that
that black bar is the out of frame end
elf and then we'll take
two different guides and this i'm
showing you the first set of guide
experiments so this is guide three and
we take a sample at day three
day five and day seven and what you can
see is the gray is the out of
sorry the in-frame mutations the black
is the out-of-frame mutations and then
the red
is the wild type length uh amplicon
so what you can see is that over between
day three and day ten after rmp
transfection of your guide plus cast
nine
you don't really see a change in the
allelic ratios uh or the indel ratios
then we also take a second guide so this
is case guide 10 so we do two different
guides to make sure that it's not just
guide dependent
and then we can also see a day three day
five days day ten you don't really see
a change in the in the end frame out of
frame mutation
so this gene is not dependent the cell
line is not dependent on this gene
and it would be you could you would be
able to knock it out
we also in this case here's a dependent
one where we take the same cell line
we take a guide rna called guide four to
a new gene gene y
and you can see that over time you lose
that black uh that black bar which is
the out of frame in delt
and then we do it with the second do the
same thing so you can see that you're
losing it over fifty percent reduction
um in the outer frame end else and so
this is easy to see that this looks like
it's a it's basically validating a hit
from a screen or showing you that it's
unlikely that you're going to be able to
get a
a knockout cell line now it is called we
call it a fitness assay because it could
just cause
say that when you knock out that gene it
causes a severe growth disadvantage but
it's not essential necessarily but it
causes a severe growth
disadvantage
so i mentioned earlier that we use cast
9 sp cas9 predominantly
and we do this because we it works
really well across a broad range of cell
type cell lines
it's got not a very restrictive pam with
just two gg's
next to each other required and it works
most of the time so i would say 90 95
percent of the guides that we use give
us high activity
but there are times where we use other
cas9 orthologs so
our i guess our second go-to cast not
cast ortholog is cast 12a
and uh there are some differences
between these um but
the reason why we like caspel bay is
because it also works very robustly
it's commercially available um you can
actually get the protein so we like to
deliver our reagents as r p if possible
um and then also it's got a t
rich pam which is nice because it
complements the g rich pam of the cast
9.
so we can cover uh more more sequence
something else that i want to point out
that i don't know if a lot of people
think about um is cast 12a has a longer
spacer region so cast 9 only has a 20
base pair spacer
20 1920 base per spacer whereas cast 12a
has a longer so
typically around 25 base pairs so what
this does is it allows you to if you're
looking at sequences that are highly
homologous to other sites in the genome
you could maybe use a cast 12a to give
you a more unique uh
guide rna or more unique cut and so
here's an example of
a nice ngs's platform agnostic because
you can use ngs for base editing prime
editing
different cast cast 9 orthologs or cast
orthologs
and in this case i'm going to show you
an example where you use cast 12a
so in this example um this gene is
highly homologous or this region is
highly homologous to several other genes
in the genome so when we look for cast
iron in dg
pam we couldn't find one um that was a
unique we like to have at least three
base pairs of mismatched to any other
site in the genome and we couldn't find
anything
that was unique but when we went to cast
12a which has the longer spacer region
we were able to find a guide rna show
here um the pam sequence is over here so
it's on the five prime end of the of the
guide
shown here we put them into the sequence
shown sorry and then
uh it's tttv and so what we want to do
this experiment is we wanted to insert
this high bit tag
directly in front of the stop codon um
and and
and what we were able to do is use cast
well they uh to find it we found a guide
on it that was
unique and had two base pairs of
mismatched so it's much more unique than
the cast 9
alternative guide and so we use this and
we introduce
the cast 12 a protein the guide rna and
then also this ssod
to insert this hibbet tag um and what
you can see here is this blocking
modification that we also introduced
again we introduced it into the pam
mutation or into the pam site so the
first t of the tctv
and then we also put it in the wobble
position so this lysine is not changed
and so our crispy analysis looks like
this so we have some negative controls
gfp only then each of the oligos by
themselves so we did this antisense in
the sense
when i say antisynth i just mean the
bottom strand and then and then sending
the top strands here
um and then we also put in the nucleus
plus those ssodiums so i can quickly go
to my total indel column
and i can look and say okay the first
three or negative controls really have
no cutting that's the sequencing error
and then
whenever we put the cast 12a you can see
that you've got a lot of cutting over 95
percent cutting 97 and 98 and each of
the well so they cut
fairly equivalently um between the two
different samples
and you can also see that the end bells
in bill number one in bill number two
and then number three are they are the
same across the two samples so you get
consistent cutting
across the two different samples in the
cell type and then the other thing we're
going to look for is that specific
modification that we wanted so we put
those as
in as our test sequences and so one of
our test sequences is guide one so we're
looking to see how often does that guide
rna site
match exactly and our controls you can
see it's very high
around 90 um or higher and then in our
experimental we can see that that guide
one goes
away almost completely down to 0.6 and
1.8 percent
and this is because we had really high
editing 97 98 percent editing
in dells and then we also had our
hibbett tag going in with that blocking
modification
the second test sequence is going to be
just that
blocking modification by itself and then
the third one is the hibbet tag
um the the sequence shown in yellow
which is 33
spacers so what we can also see is that
the anti-sense oligo worked better than
the since i'll go so
whenever we use the strand that was not
the targeting strand as the oligo donor
it works better and so if we look at the
hibbit tag column you can see that there
was
1.8 percent integration of the hibbet
tag where you when you use the
anti-sense strand but only
0.1 percent whenever you use the synth
strand and so of course we went forward
and we
we uh sequenced uh sorry we single
self-sorted
the antisense uh sample and we were able
to find um
homozygously tagged clones uh shown here
seven uh b9 and also 8 d2
um and i just wanted to show you this
how this looks different
from the pool versus the clones now when
we look at our block
only or our hibit tag you can see high
rates of those
and you can also see that the indels are
100 because we've knocked in this 33
base pair
hibbet tag
all right so another thing that we often
do is we do create large deletions so
i'm going to give you an example where
we created a large deletion
of 150 kb deletion in the cell line so
we wanted to delete all the regions
shown here in gray
and so we put in two guide rnas cas9
protein
and then we screen our pool to see if
the deletion happened by doing this pcr
where we have a gene
we call it gen f and gen r so they're
out primers
so these primers are about 150 kb apart
when they're not deleted when this
section in between is not deleted and
they're only 350 base pairs apart
whenever they are deleted
and so you're only going to get
amplicons whenever you have the deletion
of a product
and so we actually run these by ngs as
well
and what we do our little trick that you
can use is we use something called a
bridging oligo again
and what this looks like is we basically
just take 40 to 60 base pairs on either
side of
[Music]
and then we make a single stranded all
go donor so that basically we our hope
is that
basically the when you get the double
stranded break uh single stranded index
is exposed it a complementary base pair
to that end and it kind of bridges it to
the other double-stranded break
and we wanted to test this if it's
actually helping or not it was an idea
but we didn't know it was actually
helping
helping so what we do is we put in an
ecor-1 site so this g-a-a-t-t-c
on the bottom we put that in to see is
it happening from just the rejoining the
two breaks
rejoining so not anything to do with the
ssodium or bridging ssodn
or is the guide rna or the ecor1 site
being integrated into that cut site
which shows us that the
the ssod and the bridging ssodium was
used and so here's just two examples
this is the first example where we
basically use guide 42 and guide three
also i'll say that there's only one
sample coming up on our ngs data because
again
you only get an amplicon if the deletion
has occurred so all of our controls are
going to be
no reads so they won't show up on our
ngs analysis
but in our experiment or where we put
all the business in all the stuff that
we needed to make the break and rejoin
it in
we actually saw no perfect deletions we
did see 78
of our rejoining events that deletion
events we're actually incorporating the
ecor1 site
and we can also see this in our top
indel because six base pairs is the
indel
um size the most prevalent and bell size
when you look at the when you align the
sequences from the text file you can see
that our top read is
that gaa ttc being integrated that six
base pairs and the ecor1 site
and you can see we got a lot of indels
that didn't rely on the bridging
ssodin but they are not perfect
rejoining in this case it would probably
it would be fine to use that because we
were just trying to get a approximate
deletion occurring
um and that's why we were okay with the
ecor1 site
if you wanted a precise uh rejoining
event you could use an ssd in a bridging
ssodn
and not put that that core one side and
we were just doing it to see
how often the cell was using either just
rejoining or using the ssod
to fix that break those breaks
arbitrary joining does occur and i think
the smaller the in the smaller the
deletion the more likely you don't need
a bridging oligo
um this is an example where we're doing
about 100 kb so when i say small i'm
talking like 2 kb or less the bridging
oligo becomes less important
this is about 100kb deletion that we're
doing here but we did see some perfect
rejoinings in this case it was point six
percent but again
the bridging oligo helped a lot uh most
of the the deletion events actually
included that ecor one site over 50
all right so then i want to talk a
little bit about large insertions
in this case we're using single stranded
dna so something that's just a single
strand piece of dna that we have
we typically have made um and we we
typically use 200 base pairs of homology
arms so
on the five prime and the three prime
site just 200 base pairs on either side
of what you want to insert in this case
we're basically inserting this t2a cree
upstream of the stock codon and so you
can see that shown in the bottom in the
red
and what we would do is what we call
junction pcrs where we have a primer
that's outside of the homology arm gene
specific
gene f and then we also have a junk r we
call these junction
um where it's basically a primer landing
inside of the insert
then you would do each of these pcrs and
then you could submit for ngs
because these amplicons are about 400
base pairs with ngs we're really limited
to about 500 base pairs
in sequencing with illumina so what you
might do if you weren't using nds
is you could easily just run this pcr on
the gel and you'd see something like
this so here's our five prime junction
here's our three prime junction
you can see that we have 13 i think 13
maybe 15 pups 16 i don't know
something around there uh 15-inch pups
and you can see that most of the pups
are positive if they're positive for one
they're positive for both you can see
that this pup here
missed uh the five-time junction so you
wouldn't use that but other than that
you can't really distinguish between
with ngs we basically run this pcr and
then we throw it onto our ngs
run for the week and then we get the
sequences back so i'm going to show you
what the sequence looks back for the
three prime junction
um for the three prime junction we
actually have a test sequence that
goes across the junction shown here in
red and what i can immediately see is
pups one and two do not have an exact
match to that three prime junction so
something is off in these pups where
they don't have a precise rejoining
but four however has a high rate of that
um of that
of that exact match um you also see pup
uh 2 has its 98.8 percent in delta so it
has something that's not even the right
length it's not an exact match or the
right length but it does have
the junction so when we look at this in
more detail we can see that
in the very bottom which is pretty tiny
now that i see it on my laptop
um you can see that there are some
mistakes here
and we see this more often with us we
see this really only when we use ss odms
or ssdna and it's been reported
in the literature i think we talked
about talked about with steve ecker's
group
where when you're using ssodn something
about the repair process is less
efficient where you have some
mistakes at the cut site um we also see
if you look down at the other pups some
of the lower pups
um you have point mutations down here uh
shown in red on the right hand side
those i don't think those have to do
with repair i think those are more
likely a synthesis here or something to
do with the
long ssdna construction that had a
mistake in it and our
our pup just happened to use that as a
repair template
but the good news is that we did have
some pups these ones start in green that
were precise and they had exact
modification with no other errors or no
uh mistakes in the repair
again another thing that is good about
ngf but a limitation
is that we could not sequence through
the whole thing we could only sequence
through the business end
and since i talked to you about these
synthesizers it's really important to
sequence through the whole
insert before before going forward to
breeding this animal
all right just a few more slides um i
wanted to talk to you about this on
target activity limitation of pcr bias
so i mentioned this
pcr bias is seen easily and whenever
we're dealing with animals because we
know that in the f1 generation
mom can only give one allele and dad can
only give one allele so we know that it
should be messy
so this example we did embryo injections
found a pup that had a minus 33 base
pair deletion that was our f-zero
um then he was actually mosaic so he had
you know more than just two alleles but
he can only pass on one whenever you
made him to uh
or maybe i got remember boy made them to
a wild type black six
and so we know that the allylic ratio
and f1 generation should be 50 50 of
whatever we have
but when you look at the ngs data you
can see the pup 31 the very top one
had a minus 33 3 in bell at 61 percent
and my
uh and then wild type from the black
fixed parent at 36
so that larger deletion made the
amplicon about 10
smaller so the the pcr the polymerase
preferentially amplifies the smaller
endo so be aware of that whenever you're
doing any pcr-based assay whether it's
ngs
or or some ida or tighter eyes
from there and then i
talked about amplicon size and how
you're limited to really about a
thousand base pairs you can get kind of
creative with us and put more things
into your ngs run
one way we do this is whenever we use
double stranded dna which is what we
typically use for creating cell lines
we use a junction pcrs like i described
earlier but we have
in the double strand of dna we typically
use about 800 base pair homology arms
which makes this five prime junction and
the three prime junction amplicon about
900 base pairs in length
which is too big for ngs so what we do
is we'll do
actually three pcrs so we do the first
pcr which we call the long junction
then we take that pcr and we do another
pcr which we call the short junction
and then we do our indexing pcr so in
this case our short junctions
you should only give the amplicon if you
have the target integration and our
short junctions will be 400 base pairs
which we can sequence
so in this case you'll only get um reads
from the wells that have
the the the junction where you actually
have the long junction
and so you can do this since our output
is in excel you can either create
something in python which is what we did
or you can do something in excel we
compare how many pups had the five prime
positive how many pups had the
three prime positive or cell lines
clones and you can actually figure out
which ones have
uh both the five prime and three prime
junctions to know which ones to narrow
down fairly quickly
and so in this example 62 percent of the
clones that had the five prime
correct junction also had the three
prime correct junction
and then i also mentioned earlier uh
that there's a high barrier to entry for
ngs we hope that christy has helped with
the
you should not be intimidated by it
crispy again was written
by a guy who just learned how to do
python coding for this particular
application so it's super simple
um and then the cost is the other thing
that's barrier so what we've done to
make
ngs cost effective and actually cheaper
than finger sequencing in our case
um are several things and i just wanted
to share some tips
one is the more samples the better so we
sequence anything we can sequence we
throw into our weekly sample so we
sequence guide on a plasmas we take
those pools we sequence clones we do
junctions deletions translocations we
even do spr profiling to identify cell
identity
um so you can put anything you think you
put in there you should put in there
because
the more the better you can also pool
samples so we basically pull the samples
and we only do
one run a week so we basically take all
the samples that we can get all over
think jude
we run one week one run a week so that
we can make get the most bang for our
buck
you can also consider trying a spike in
program so if you don't need a lot of
reads but several other labs are
interested in getting some reads
um just the reagents cost from illumina
for the my sequin is about four hundred
dollars and you get a million reads
the my seat uh the sorry that was the
nano run the full run you get 15 million
reads and it's only 1200
for the reagents so you get 15 times the
number of reads and it's only three
times the cost so if you can get the
more rate more people that you can get
doing sequencing or the more samples
that you have
the cheaper it becomes we use the two
two-step pcr because it's generally more
effective versus like a true seeker you
have to use specific
primers um and then we try to make our
our setup as quick
and easy as possible so we do robotics
when possible on the pcr we use crude
lysis for the genomic dna and we use a
multi-drop to just fast dispense the
reagents
and so my last two slides are really
just going to kind of sum up this
notion that nds can actually be cheaper
than singer sequencing so hopefully it's
not going to be a barrier for you to
enter into this
spot so i mentioned that a mysq
full run is twelve hundred dollars for
the reagents i get that there's a
machine and the service contract also
involved but just the reagents
are twelve hundred dollars um you get
about fifteen million reads
typically if you do a thousand x cup
which is overkill for most of the things
that we are doing in our lab
um you could do 15 000 samples and that
will basically be
uh eight cents or eight cents a sample
so it's much cheaper than sanger
sequencing even if you add in
the cost of the service agreement and
the labor involved in
hiring somebody to help would run this
let's say you don't need 10 million
or 15 million reads you can do a nano
kit which is about 400
you get about a million reads if you
want a thousand x coverage you can do a
thousand samples
and this is only 40 cents a sample so
still again cheaper than zinger
sequencing and you get a lot of
information
so in conclusion i hope i've shown you
basically three main things
one ngs is an excellent on-target assay
for crispr activity
it's also good for off-target activity
but we use it really to figure out do we
have the modification that we want
also crispy is this python-based program
that is freely available on github and
it allows even novice users to
interrogate their data completely like
you can really dig down and figure out
what was the cell doing what did the
cell do in my and myself it's not a
black box that's really hard to
understand it's very simple and and
again i've trained a lot of scientists
on how to use this and interpret it
and it's very simple and then finally
ngs is a high throughput method for
quickly cost effectively and
quantitatively measuring your editing
outcomes
and then i'm going to leave you with
thinking the people who did all the work
um so i've been
i basically started the center uh the
geic at washington university
uh monica setman out was the one that
led the survey of the validation assays
with the help of
patrick connolly sam peters and colin
florian i also
mentioned patrick several times because
he was the one that developed the the
crispy python program and then really
we're very much a team
so everybody in both organizations was
involved in
and and these the data that i presented
today and then also the things the
funding
and i'll leave you uh with a picture of
the folks in my lab now
um who are working diligently every day
and then i'll take any questions that we
might have
and thank you dr miller for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
dr miller we already have some great
questions
coming in our first audience member says
thank you for your helpful presentation
based on your experience for knocking
out a bacterial virulence gene
that contains both the conserved and
hypervariable regions which
part is better for targeting
this is a question that i uh probably
cannot answer
because we haven't done that um i i
guess i assume that they're
talking well i'm not exactly sure what
they're specifically asking
um but typically whenever you're
knocking out a gene i mean you could
definitely delete the whole
thing like the two guy approach um if
you're worried about it
um but but i would say most of the time
if you get an indel in there it'll it'll
it'll mess it up it'll cause it not to
be expressed um
but i would say if you're really worried
about it just do a deletion where you
delete the whole thing out
um if it's going to be small most most
genes are 1200 base pairs or less if
you're looking at the cdna
um so i would say deletions of 1200
bases are fairly efficient so that would
be no problem at all
wonderful thank you we have time for one
more question
is crispy available for download and if
so
how can i download the program
yeah absolutely so i encourage you to go
to the paper that i
probably that we published um to patrick
colley the first author
crispy i think if you if you search for
crispy and st dude you'll find it
you may find something about fried
chicken i'm not sure um
but uh yes you can absolutely download
it there's a link to get the github site
and that also has a link to the pretty
crispy where you can use the gui
the user interface absolutely we wanted
to make it available to everybody and if
you have questions we're happy to help
um but yeah it's definitely available
and there's that tutorial too that can
help you um
and your first go at it
dr miller thank you again for your time
today and for your important research
and before we go i also want to thank
our audience members for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
provided at the time of registration and
this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months until march of 2021
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care
stay healthy bye